I want a simple task for that the most
dangerous people on the planet they're
bad guys worst of the worst what was
that I should kill everyone in this gate
sorry the voices let's play
don't forget we're the bad guys
hey youtubers it's Charlie new Suicide
Squad teaser and there's been a whole
bunch of stuff going on behind the
scenes so let's bring it down a lot of
you probably heard they've been test
screening Suicide Squad they might even
be screening it at comic-con but that's
unconverted a but they have been
screening it around the country for test
audiences everyone seems to like it they
actually do this a lot with big movies
like this well they'll privately show it
around without really telling people
what movie they're going to see usually
it's places you've never heard of and
they try to get like the most average
moviegoer they could possibly find so
someone who doesn't read a lot of comics
isn't vastly aware of the characters or
what's been going on with the drama
behind the movie they just want to find
out what the average person thinks about
you know whatever cut of the film it is
that they're showing so the idea is is
they use feedback from those test
screenings to tune the film before they
get the wide release all around the
world but everyone seems to like it so
far and I would not be surprised if
Geoff Johns has been spending every last
minute of his free time trying to make
sure the film is that a hundred percent
before the release so a lot of this
footage is repeated from the Bohemian
Rhapsody longer trailer which I actually
think is one of the best trailers for
any movie in the last year next to
spider-man Civil War those are my two
favorite trailers this year so far but I
would be willing to bet based on the
stuff that's happening behind the scenes
that this film marks a really nice
balance between the silliness of
Deadpool in the really hardcore nature
of Batman V Superman there were a lot of
really good things in Batman V Superman
but there were some story issues in the
tone of Superman was just way off there
was a lot of great Batman in there but
the film just wasn't quite as balanced
as it need to be so I think suicide
squad will be the answer to that they
have more characters they have Harley
quit Harley Quinn is really going to
balance the tone of the film her
characters kind of meta commentary on
the film itself she's someone who
vacillates between like really crazy
Deadpool silliness and just really
hardcore WTF Joker moments so what about
justice league stuff I know a lot of you
are asking are they going to be teasing
any other things for the other movies
there will be some stuff for the other
movies but I'm expecting that they're
probably trying to minimize that just to
keep the film under control usually wear
big movies like this run into trouble is
where they try to do too many things so
outside of the Batman moments I'm just
expecting brief teasers for what's going
to be going on in Justice League because
they are filming that right now so we
might actually see some justice league
teasers
dropping around Suicide Squad later this
year the other big thing that's coming
with this movie is all the Suicide Squad
rebirth comic book stuff so if you're
following along in the comics they've
really just released the big a list
titles like Batman Superman the flash so
they're like the tip of the rebirth
spear by the time we get to august and
october that's when you'll see harley
quinn rebirth you'll see Suicide Squad
rebirth so those comics aren't coming to
a little bit later so if you want to
read along with all the DC rebirth stuff
that's happening and you want like some
Suicide Squad related stuff I would
recommend you just go with Batman
rebirth they're doing this really weird
thing where Clayface is now on Team
Batman so most of you should be able to
check that on on comiXology if you don't
have a comic book store nearby a lot of
people ask me where to buy digital
comics all of the digital stuff that I
read is from comiXology they're owned by
amazon it's pretty much everywhere
around the world so you should be able
to buy your comicsdigital II if you
can't make it to a store but that
actually reminds me I'm doing a giveaway
right now it's a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card which will actually buy you a
lot of comics so all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll announce
the winner when i post a flash rebirth
video later today so if I didn't mention
it I think it's actually pretty obvious
you guys have probably picked up on this
that the comic books have started to
follow the movies a little bit it's not
quite the same as it is with Marvel
Marvel's comics really take their energy
from the movies now DC isn't quite there
yet because they've just started to spin
out this greater Cinematic Universe so
you'll start to see that more and more
where the movie characters are getting
this rebirth of sorts a hand of Geoff
Johns is reaching into the movie machine
tuning the characters a little bit
refreshing certain elements of the story
then you see a lot of that same stuff
happening in the comics so no surprises
but currently my favorite rebirth comics
right now i'll talk about this a little
bit more of my flash rebirth video but
green arrow rebirth is a lot of fun in
flash rebirth so be sure to check them
out the artwork is amazing i love how
harley looks like she's trying to crawl
out of my monitor here but while you
guys wait for my flash rebirth video you
can click here for my injustice to
trailer video that's coming next year
but I talked a little bit about what's
going on with the game and you can click
here to learn all about Superman coming
into the flash arrow universe thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight